ض بالفعل مريم وكان الحرب تحولت على هذه
المستشفيات منذ بدايه الحرب الاسرائيليه
واسرائيل تشن حربها على هذه المستشفيات
وتخرجها من الخدمه اخرجت مستشفى الشفاء
وها هي تعود اليه مستشفى الامل في خانيونس
التابع للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ايضا
مازال محاصرا هو والعاملين فيه من اطباء
من ممرضين وايضا مركز حي الامل او مركز
الامل التابع ايضا للهلال الاحمر والذي
استضاف الالاف من النازحين الفلسط ين
الذين ما زالوا يتواجدون في هذا المركز هم
جاؤوا الى هذا المركز على انه على اساس
انه امن هو تابع للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
وبالتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاصر ما زال
هذا المركز بالعاملين فيه وحتى يمنع
سيارات الاسعاف من المعروف ان جمعيه
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني هي الاهم والابرز
والاكثر قدره على التوجه الى مناطق مناطق
القصف الاسرائيلي واجلاء المصابين والجرحى
الان هذا المركز الاساسي في مدينه خانيونس
بات محاصرا في مستشفى الامل وبجانبه ايضا
هذا المركز ايضا مستشفى ناصر محاصر لليوم
الثامن على التوالي الاطباء الممرضين
المرضى النازحين الذين يتواجدون في مستشفى
ناصر لا يجدون لا ماء ولا غذاء ولا حتى
ولا حتى الدواء الاصابات على بعد امتار
منهم ولا يستطيعون اجلاء بسبب استمرار
القصف الاسرائيلي القصف مركز على مدينه
خان يونس القصف منذ عده ايام منذ ثمانيه
ايام على الاقل القصف والعمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في المناطق الغربيه لمدينه
خان يونس مركزه تستهدف المستشفى ومحيطه
وايضا تستهدف حي الامل وكذلك تستهدف منطقه
بطن السمين والمناطق المحيطه بهذه المنطقه
الجنوبيه ل مستشفى ناصر وبالتالي هناك
عمليات قصف مستمره ومتواصله قبل قليل كان
هناك قصف مدفعي في تلك المناطق والجيش
الاسرائيلي مازال يتواجد على على الشارع
الرئيسي في المنطقه الغربيه لمدينه
خانيونس وبالتالي حتى عمليه النزوح هي
عمليه صعبه بل تكاد تكون خطيره في ظل
استمرار الجيش الاسرائيلي في عمليات القصف
في ظل استمراره في اغلاق الشوارع المؤديه
الى مدينه رفح واقتصارها على شارع واحد
ومن ثم يعتقل هؤلاء السكان يعتقل الرجال
يترك النساء وهؤلاء هؤلاء النسوى الذين
يذهبون الى مدينه رفح يجبرهم الجيش
الاسرائيلي على ترك امتعتهم ترك فراشهم
وترك كل ما يحت كل ما اخذوه واستطاعوا
الحصول عليه من منازلهم او من مناطق
النزوح وبالتالي يذهبون الى رفح الى
المجهول بلا ماوى بلا غذاء بلا دواء في ظل
احوال جويه صعبه وسيئه للغايه وبالتالي
هناك حاله كارثيه يعيشها السكان ومن
المعروف ان مدينه رفح باتت لا تستطيع
استيعاب هذا العدد الكبير من النازحين نحن
نتحدث عن نصف سكان مدينه غزه الذين يقدر
عددهم باكثر من 2 مليون فلسطيني يتواجدون
الان في رفح وبالتالي كل هذا العدد الكبير
يحتاج الى مقومات يحتاج الى بنى تحتيه
يحتاج الى ماوى وهذا هو الاهم بالاضافه
الى انه يحتاج الى مقومات حياه كغذاء
ومياه وهذا غير متوفر رغم ان مدينه رفح
ربما تعتبر افضل حالا من كثير من محافظات
قطاع غزه في ظل وجود معبر رفح ودخول بعض
المساعدات الشحيحه الى المدينه ولكن رغم
كل ذلك هذا العدد كبير يحتاج الى مقومات
كبيره ويحتاج الى مساعدات كثيره بدنا ه يا
عرب شكرا جزيلا لك هشام زقوت من رفح